[Music]
the horror genre always seems to be
evolving
some of these changes happen slowly but
occasionally a single movie rocks the
foundation of horror to such a degree
that the genre is never the same
here are some of the scare fest that
redefine the horror genre and our
nightmares
a nightmare on elm street for a long
time horror movies were relatively
straightforward with a monster
or like a crazy person but then came a
nightmare on elm street a film that
blurred the line between reality and
fantasy creating a teen slasher with a
supernatural twist
in many ways it was pretty much the
first of its kind
what makes this concept so genius is
that since freddy krueger played an
otherworldly role in the film
it left room to keep bringing him back
for sequels
lots of them actually to wreak havoc on
teens and insane ways that actually fit
the story
other franchises attempted the same
supernatural slant but they ended up
just creating a bunch of crazy guys with
super strength who never seemed to die
no matter how many times you shoot them
it really wasn't until
child's play stuck the soul of a serial
killer into a doll's body
that another film successfully blurred
the lines between reality and the
supernatural
but the ninth-fingered man of our
nightmares went on to become an
icon in the horror world showing it's
not easy to make a freaky killer that
can endure for decades
jaws you might think jaws isn't really a
true horror film
to that we say go watch the beginning
and come back
go ahead we'll wait
terrifying right the creature is
basically unstoppable and with no rhyme
or reason starts killing
everyone in its path jaws popularized
the giant monsters eating people genre
for a new age
if it weren't for jaws that genre either
wouldn't exist or at the very least
wouldn't be nearly as vibrant as it is
today
while it wasn't the first film to do so
the way jaws portrayed the terrifying
creature
almost always in shadows seeming more a
malevolent force than anything that you
could actually defeat would influence
movies for years to come
after jaws came dozens of copies that
were basically just jaws with a
different animal
a bunch of them were amazingly bad
remember anaconda
sorry you do now some were great like
lake placid
and some were even made by spielberg but
none of them would have existed if not
for that pesky man-eating shark
the blair witch project when the blair
witch project hit theaters in 1999
many moviegoers didn't know what to make
of the horrifyingly realistic film
the movie's shaky camera work
documentary style production
and nose dripping close-ups were
elements no one had seen before
plenty of people left the theaters
thinking the footage was real
after blair witch popularized the found
footage genre many aspiring filmmakers
applied the idea to their own projects
thanks to the relatively low budget
needed for filming newcomers prove that
practically anyone could make a movie
using this technique though making a
good one still proved to be a challenge
as technology evolves so does this genre
smartphones
gopros and security cameras allow found
footage to provide different viewpoints
like what we see in movies like
paranormal activity and cloverfield
even the last season of american horror
story used found footage
setting up a house with hidden cameras
and locking up people with just a
smartphone so they could record their
own murders
the shining stanley kubrick's adaptation
of stephen king's novel
showed that you didn't need cheap scare
tactics and obnoxious music to make the
audience jump
instead hotel scenes were kept well lit
and ghosts were hallucinations caused by
jack torrance's cabin fever and creeping
insanity
using savvy camera angles and
intelligent dialogue the shining
redefined what it meant to be a horror
movie
the hotel's creepy sense of isolation is
emphasized by the shockingly small
number of scenes that feature all three
members of jack's family together
also unlike horror movies before the
shining most of what could be classified
as the scary stuff
doesn't occur until the end of the movie
while the rest is portrayed in a space
blurred between reality and fantasy
texas chainsaw massacre the movie where
we first met
leatherface and his favorite toy is
notable for being one of the most
realistic depictions of what it's like
to live in texas
no not the murdery parts but some parts
of texas are terrifying all on their own
those big empty wastes where there's
nothing around but fields
and then a small house off in the
distance it's on roads like these that
the heroes of this film wonder
finding horror as they pick up a stray
hitchhiker only to realize he's
dangerously mad
and he's the nicest member of his family
texas chainsaw massacre was amazing for
its time
it was one of the most brutal films ever
made when it came out
and it defined what slashers would come
to be savage
horrifying and sometimes just a tiny bit
inspired by real life
despite a slew of successors none have
ever come close to making the ferocious
horror let loose by leatherface
who oh yeah is wearing a mask made out
of people's skin
the first time you see him slaughter and
the body twitches in
death that's an image that'll stick with
you whether you like it or not
alien there have been sci-fi movies with
giant monsters before but never a
straight up horror film about them
then alien came along not only did it
bring about a renewal and body horror
across all science fiction but it also
created the modern concept of science
fiction horror films
if it weren't for alien we would have
never gotten films like event horizon or
pandora but being the excellent film it
is
alien wasn't content with simply
creating a genre it also redefined how
horror films operated
before this final girls the girls who
lasted until the end of the movie and
occasionally won
were already a thing but with alien came
a bold new era of girls who were as
fearsome as the monsters themselves
changing how horror film protagonists
worked forever after
scream this wes craven classic brought
horror fans back into theaters
after many had grown tired of watching
the never-ending sequels of 80s slasher
flicks
just how many times could jason and
michael myers possibly die
scream introduced a fresh post-modern
take on the genre
completely changing the formula for teen
horror films craven made sure his
characters were familiar with the tropes
of those movies too
knowledge that would be useful when
their phones rang for instance
number one you can never have sex
scream all but invented the
self-referential self-aware horror movie
even the killer took time out of his
bloody rampage to make horror movie
references
as he asks his victims trivia in order
to decide whether they live or die
in order to stay alive the teens think
they can use what they know from slasher
films
creating a set of rules to follow like
not having sex not doing drugs
and absolutely never saying i'll be
right back
[Applause]
paranormal activity when it comes to
paranormal activity
you either love it or hate it it was
filmed with a handheld camera that
almost
anyone could afford in someone's house
with almost no special effects
there's almost no plot no professional
actors and no real big scares to be seen
it's either a pretty great film or the
worst film ever made
depending on who you talk to no matter
what you think about it though there's
one undeniable fact
it helped usher in a huge surge of new
found footage horror movies
it wasn't the first obviously but with
the success of paranormal activity
a movie made for next to no money it
showed movie studios that people would
gobble up
found footage it even helped keep the
sub genre alive long enough for a blair
witch reboot
thank paranormal activity even if a
whole lot of people thought it was
boring
it gave us a ton of movies that weren't
knight of the living dead
one of the best movies ever made knight
of the living dead is completely free to
watch because george romero didn't
copyright it
it's not his fault though he wasn't an
experienced filmmaker at the time
the movie was his first and it was
basically made with couch cushion change
despite that it became one of the most
influential horror films in history
not only did it bring about a
renaissance in independent film making
it introduced the world to a classic
horror staple
the slow flesh-eating zombies before
night of the living dead
most zombies were magically controlled
beings finding their roots in the
western ideas of voodoo
but romero changed all that he
introduced creatures that rose from the
dead
not due to any magic but because of
science while it's not explicitly said
what
exactly caused the creatures to rise all
of the theories concern nasa probes and
viruses that's all stuff that exists in
the real world
turning zombies from fantasy monsters
into science fiction horror
the amityville horror when it was first
released in 1979
the amityville horror was already
familiar to the world thanks to the
real-life murders that inspired the
story
the film fleshed things out giving
viewers more details about the infamous
house whether the details were all true
or
not and it revolutionized the idea that
a horror film could be based on real
life events
while other horror films have certainly
claimed to be based on true events
they're usually so
loosely based that the film hardly
deserves that subtitle
the amityville horror however used news
reports about the events
interviewed police who reported to the
scene of the actual murders
and depicted the experiences of the lutz
family as close
as they could during filming the success
of the movie inspired several
other paranormal movies like poltergeist
and demonstrated how audiences are
suckers for horror flicks based on a
true story even if it may not
actually be all that true saw and
hostile
yeah we're cheating and putting two
movies together but it's only because
they came out at around the same time
before saw and hostile came out horror
movies were very gore-field and
very scary but there were also typically
plots and ideas
they were you know actual movies not
just celebrations of gore
it wasn't until saw and hostile came
around that the idea of torture based
horror became an actual thing
it led to a slew of horror movies that
don't care about much outside of shock
and awe
no plot no point nothing but blood guts
gore and torture if it weren't for these
films horror movies today
wouldn't be anywhere nearly as overtly
brutal and graphic
and what kind of world would that be
thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our youtube channel plus check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love too